we're told that the glass portion of the
window shown below that's the window has
a height to width ratio of 3 to 2. so
the height of the glass portion can be
represented as 3x so the height of the
glass portion can be represented as 3x
as 3x and the width of the glass portion
can be represented as 2x the width of
the glass portion can be represented as
2x the wood trim adds seven inches to
the total width and eight inches to the
total height
so let me write that down so eight in
height we're doing it in yellow
so eight inches to the total height i'll
do it in yellow and seven inches to the
total width i'll do in this purplish
color right we're doing the width in
purple
now what they say is write a polynomial
expression that represents the total
area of the wood
sorry that the total area of the window
including the glass and wood simplify
the expression now the way they've
described it so they're telling us the
ratio of three to two for the glass
portion now i think when they're talking
about the glass portion they're talking
about this entire portion right here
this entire portion right here even
though it's not all glass you have that
thing in the middle
you have this divider right here right
over here that's not glass but i think
they're including that as the glass
portion because they're not giving us
any measurements for that so this glass
portion in the glass the height of the
glass portion can be represented as 3x
so this height right here of the just
the glass portion is 3x
you can't see that let me do it in a
better color
this portion right here is 3x just this
distance right here that is the height
of the glass portion and then they tell
us that the wood trim adds 8 inches to
the total height so if you take that 3x
and then you add
that plus that this whole distance this
whole distance over here which is the
glass portion plus the wood trim on
either end it would add
it adds 8 inches to the glass portion
the glass portion is 3x
so we're going to add 8 to it so this
height right here is 3x plus 8. and now
let's think about the width the width of
the glass portion can be represented as
2x so that distance right there just the
glass portion is 2x but then they say
when you add when you add the wood trim
the wood trim adds 7 inches to the total
width so this total width right here
because we're adding we're adding that
piece and that piece to it is 2x plus 7
2 x plus 7. that is the total width of
the window the total height is 3x plus
8. now what they want us to do is write
a polynomial expression that represents
the total area of the window including
the glass and wood simplify the
expression now the total area is just
going to be the height times the width
so let's just write that down the area
is just going to be equal to the height
the height which is three x plus eight
times the width times two x plus seven
times two x
plus seven
and that is the expression we've written
well we haven't done a polynomial we've
written it as a product of two binomials
and if we want to simplify it we can
just multiply it out so the way you can
think about it is we multiply you're
doing the distributive property twice
essentially but you can say let's let's
multiply 3x times 2x so you get 3x
times 2x
times 2x that's multiplying it times
that then you want to multiply 3x times
multiply 3x times 7 which is 21x let me
just write it this way plus
plus 3x times 7.
and then you want to multiply this 8
times both of these terms
so then you have
plus 8 times 2x
let me do this so plus
8 times
2x
and then you have plus
8 times 7. so plus eight times seven so
plus
eight times seven and now we just have
to simplify everything so what does this
become
three x times two x is six
x squared
plus 3x times 7 is plus 21x
plus 8 times 2x is so plus 16
x and then plus 8 times 7 8 times 7 is
56 plus 56 we can combine these two
middle terms 21x plus 16x is what 37x so
then we get just another color 6x
squared
plus
37x
plus 56. now we've expressed it as a
simplified polynomial simplified
polynomial expression